[Applause]
so tonight we're gonna put the wood
floor in the loft and we're using this
amazing wood right here this is Douglas
fir that was taken from windfall and
milled up this is some old beautiful
stuff and it wasn't cut down for these
purposes it was just milled up and it's
gorgeous and it smells wonderful it's
amazing I just want to eat it and it
looks like a piece of cake anyway this
is gonna be our floor what we're gonna
do is show you all how to do a pattern
floor if you want to create some sort of
cool pattern in your flooring tonight
we're going to do it in a starburst
hexagonal design and that's because the
joists the floor rafters the floor
joists that we've laid are laid out in a
particular way and the way you lay out
your floor joists and your rafters that
really determines how you're going to
end up flooring it or at least guides
the process so that's what we're gonna
do and and cut to a cut to a picture of
the floor joists thank you okay good
what the joists look like okay that's
really bad but you get the idea it's
like it's a starburst let's call each of
these sections a pie all right there's
the six pies that we have to fill in
this piece right here is the center is
the start of every single pie and then
the joists come out like this so this is
the first piece now we're gonna get the
second piece of our first pie first I'm
gonna set the saw to 30 and cut myself a
60 degree angle
with wood that's this thick and
douglas-fir is so strong and indents I
will if you'll notice I go back and
forth with the saw again and again I'm
not trying to just plunge it down and
take it all out in one swipe you kind of
got to just shave it off a little bit
shave it off right just shave it off a
little bit I mark where the other joist
comes out at the same angle as this spin
back to 30 now I have my first piece and
then of the pie slice I have my second
piece we're gonna flip this and I
already have this angle cut for the next
piece so without having to waste any
wood I'm gonna line this up right here
mark it first we started with a hexagon
and then going out at the same angle
we've got the first piece of the pattern
okay then
the long piece the long edge of this
piece gives us the short edge of the
next piece like that then we get the
short edge of the following piece by the
long edge of the previous piece and
what's so cool is that we got this all
from one board just by flipping the
board because if I have a piece like
this and I cut off this little guy right
here and flip it it's the same angle
does that make sense now that we got all
the boards covering to come upstairs in
the loft and see if they fit
fingers crossed start with our Keystone
our center piece our hexagon put that
right in the middle I'm not gonna fasten
these I'm just gonna lay them out for
you and fasten them later but here we
have all the vertexes or vertices of the
hexagon lined up with a joist you know
it's good if this line this edge splits
the each of these joists in half thing
see if the second one one does feel like
link in the Legend of Zelda I feel like
I'm on the show guts from the 90s like
I'm solving an ancient puzzle right now
which David Attenborough was not
narrating this the carpenter ladies each
bore down as carefully as he cut it and
the one before and that proceeded is
fastened with utter care I love you
David Attenborough please don't be mad
at me let's see if the final board fits
I hope no one's standing under me oh
Jesus Christ
cuz that would have sucked BAM okay now
assuming that no one got bludgeoned to
death by a falling piece of wood success
so last night I made all the cuts for
the loft floor but it was way too dark
so I wait till the next morning
of course it's raining but what can we
expect in the rain forest I'm happy to
be out here we're gonna lay down the
floorboards make sure that they all fit
screw them in and then move on to the
next thing all the pieces have been cut
if they've been staged that means
they're ready to go and in order where I
want them to be put Sara's down there
she's gonna hand them up to me one at a
time we're gonna make sure they fit then
we're gonna screw them on it all right
let's start with this pie right here
[Music]
maybe not like the average TV carpenter
in that I don't really care about things
being absolutely perfect so if you come
in here you check this out
we've got gaps here in the floor gaps
right here not all of these joints are
absolutely perfectly tight these are not
lined up perfectly I D see I don't care
you look at it from the bottom you don't
see any of that really and imperfections
are beautiful now like to a certain
extent of course but gaps are good
that's what I think I mean it means it's
really know also I I don't think I could
ever do something perfect even if I try
self that's my explanation for it ready
and then we're gonna go down to it are
your marks don't fall off and don't die
well let's get'em screw it in so I don't
die
[Music]
you're cheating a cheater
that's why Hey not like the bachelor
kind of cheater not like the bachelor
cheater that's there in paradise oh my
god you won but you cheated so that
doesn't count
hey I already pre screwed a bunch of
mine and also I gave you a battery that
was half drained we have a we have a
loss we have a lot so beautiful up here
it's amazing laughs this is what its
gonna be like you're on your phone sighs
man I like this and hopefully rains not
falling on your face but yeah let's
build a roof so we can enjoy that smart
[Music]
[Applause]
please be sure to LIKE and subscribe
this channel so you never miss an update
and please back us on patreon so we can
keep these free videos coming yes free
ain't free we need you back us please